Hey Conan O'Brien here you know behind
every great NCAA basketball team is an
iconic mascot that wits the crowd into a
frenzy
Michigan State Spartan the Florida Gator
the Kentucky Wildcat
but there's one mascot I thought needed
a little help actually a lot of help UC
Irvine's Peter the anteater I just did
this cool to see what I could do well
this is nice I'm here with Helen and
Maria thanks for meeting with me here
yeah yeah
a lot of women become suspicious when
the essent can you meet me alone in a
gymnasium show so you have chosen the
animal that's pretty much blind and
sucks ants using its two-foot long time
to its long nose that's the animal that
best represents you see your line what
you're allowed to say fly here oh I have
to say no would you ladies be open to
possibly seeing some improvements for
Peter the anteater that I thought of
sure as you know the anteater is an
animal with very poor eyesight so I
thought this might reflect a more honest
version of Peter
it's gonna be impossible for me to meet
Peter now I'd like to meet him and speak
to him I'm gonna make that happen maybe
a network Wow okay
it's like he's the Dalai Lama or
something okay this is exciting the
moment we've all been waiting for here
is Peter
[Music]
hey do you speak you don't know no
speaking okay
you don't speak how do you pump up the
crowd okay that looks like you'd caught
fire and you're trying to put it out or
you're tackled by a fireman it would it
be possible to talk to the man inside
the costume is that something it's
possible I will wear your features and
it will distort your voice and that way
no one will ever know who the real you
is cuz that's something I want to
respect is that cool you seem like a
really good guy when you're are you I'm
just over new second year came in good
shape can you
see I go much further down here because
of the nose best is an eddy okay we've
now been joined by Sam Sam assists you
is that correct you suppose you come up
with the moves now Sam
we're not going to hide your identity
there's no reason to but we are going to
distort your voice just cuz it's fun you
go with that alright that's why I
brought some materials they all like to
pitch you okay guys I just went to the
costume department mmm this is a
licensed Conan O'Brien head look at that
and look at his face
same face thanks Dora sure oh yeah pull
the string pull the string then a third
time and then cut it and then drop the
hip yeah we've cut it with the other
hand the hand that's holding the string
can't also cut it to the next level
thank you here we go in the entire game
of basketball college basketball you the
one mascot that comes out and you
prepare tableside guacamole for people
in the stands you can have the Conan
head free this one time no charge and
then put together this crap and make a
body and then try some my moves and we
see how it goes
please welcome the UC Irvine chicken
bangle Conan
yeah
[Applause]
I also found this trident
so yeah you're also like ruler of the
sea your little friend
right cuz look at this guy this guy's
got energy this guy's got probably the
gene for alcoholism
[Applause]
Tigers taking come in with the tide of
buoys como Tiger ticking Conan
[Applause]
you